there's an art to finding the right
actor for a role and sometimes
filmmakers need to see what they don't
want before they're able to settle on
what they do it's easy to imagine that
the stars who play our favorite film
characters were the first and only
people considered that's not always the
case
hard as it might be to believe these
iconic roles could have easily ended up
in different hands Stuart Townsend as
Aragorn everyone is familiar with Viggo
Mortensen's captivating portrayal of
Aragorn a ranger of the north and
eventual king of Gondor and the lord of
the rings as great as he is Mortensen
actually scooped the role from Stuart
Townsend who spent two months training
before he was let go
Townsend would go on to his own
successes but he didn't look back on his
brush with middle-earth fondly telling
Entertainment Weekly I did get shafted I
was there rehearsing and training for
two months and was fired the day before
filming began that's some Sauron level
treachery right there Sean Connery as
Gandalf
yes Peter Jackson and his team
originally intended for crotchety Sean
Connery to play Gandalf the Grey but
Connery refused it's not the first big
role Connery turned down either other
rejected roles include Dumbledore from
the Harry Potter series John Hammond
from Jurassic Park and Morpheus in the
matrix as far as the Lord of the Rings
casting went he told the New Zealand
Herald I never understood it I read the
book I read the script I saw the movie I
still don't understand it I would be
interested in doing something that I
didn't fully understand but not for 18
months luckily we ended up with Sir Ian
McKellen as the lovable wizard and
static Will Smith as Django the list of
r-rated movie starring Will Smith is
pretty short but despite this he was
originally written in as the hero in
Django Unchained he didn't pass on the
movie just to maintain his wholesome
image however Smith revealed to
Entertainment Weekly that he didn't want
to play the character after finding out
that he wasn't originally going to be
playing the lead or going to be killing
the bad guy after The Fresh Prince
passed Django became the lead character
anyway with Christoph Waltz's dr. King
Schultz stepping aside for Jamie Foxx to
take the spotlight sorry well Robert
Downey jr. as lieutenant Matthew
Kowalski when we think about Robert
Downey jr. these days we tend to picture
his head stuck in the Iron Man helmet a
picture Tony Stark a Sandra Bullock's
co-star at gravity as he told Howard
Stern down he passed on the role because
he just couldn't stand this
special effects rug that he was strapped
into coincidentally Scarlett Johansson
was also a potential candidate for
Bullock's role
we're pretty sure two Avengers could
have made it back from space with no
problems but then again there's only so
many times we can see Downey floating
helplessly in space Chris Farley as
Shrek Mike Myers performance as the
lovable ogre helped make Shrek an
instant classic but prior to Myers
voicing the green guy a large portion of
the film's dialogue was recorded by
Chris Farley aah help a big stupid
stinky smelly ugly ogre I'm so scared
his untimely death in 1997 derailed
production resulting in major delays
luckily Shrek was able to find a
suitable voice courtesy of Farley's
friend and former Saturday Night Live
cast mate meg Ryan Diane Lane and
Michelle Pfeiffer as Vivian Ward pretty
woman pretty much launched Julia Roberts
career but she only got the role of the
hooker with a heart of gold after a
bunch of bigger names past first
director Garry Marshall originally had
meg Ryan lined up to play the part of
Vivian Ward after she departed the
project Diane Lane got as far as costume
fittings before dropping out Michelle
Pfeiffer caught Marshalls eye which he
also declined the role leaving them the
hands of the relatively unknown Roberts
who was just 21 at the time it turned
out that she was the perfect person to
fall in love with Richard Gere on screen
and sell a truckload of Roxette Records
along the way Meryl Streep as Ellen
Ripley Sigourney Weaver Brooks cinematic
barriers of female badassery and the
Alien franchise but the production team
originally had its eye on Meryl Streep
for the role of Ellen Ripley
the actress dropped out prior to the
start of production because of the death
of her boyfriend
Godfather actor John Cazale upon
Streep's exit Scott briefly turned to
Veronica Carr tried to play Ripley and
then switch things up again giving the
role to Weaver Cartwright was instead
given the part of chief navigator
Lambert several decades in classic films
later it's obvious he made the right
choice Oh J Simpson as the Terminator
surprisingly our own Swardson Edgar had
a Juke past a football great to score
the role of the unrelenting t800 cyborg
at the 1984 sci-fi classic The
Terminator Entertainment Weekly reported
that Orion Pictures co-founder Mike
Medavoy wanted Oh Jay Simpson to star of
the Terminator saying at the time OJ
Simpson how one of those commercials for
Hertz were he jumped over a counter and
ran to get a rental car it was all of
that athletic stuff which I thought the
Terminator should
have Medavoy was so set on having
Simpson as the t800 that he offered
Schwarzenegger the role of Kyle Reese
which would ultimately be played by
Michael Biehn thankfully common sense
intervened or maybe it was Skynet Bill
Murray as Batman by the time Michael
Keaton donned the Caped Crusader's cowl
another take on the character had
already spent years in development an
earlier project simply called the Batman
had stalled due to the deaths of a few
potential casting choices and director
Ivan Reitman took the reins in his new
version he initially wanted Bill Murray
to play Batman with Eddie Murphy as
Robin when you think about Keaton's
Bruce Wayne the idea of Bill Murray in
the part doesn't seem all that
far-fetched
except maybe picturing him the Batsuit
eventually Warner Brothers handed the
reins to Tim Burton who acts the Batman
script completely and gave us the 1989
Batman we all know and love everyone in
ghostbusters believe it or not Paul
pee-wee Herman Reubens was originally
intended to play gozer the gozerian at
the end of ghostbusters that's just one
of the many ways in which the 1984
comedy horror classic changed during its
journey to the screen dan Aykroyd who
wrote the script with meatballs in
Animal House vet Harold Ramis originally
envisioned a futuristic time-traveling
adventure starring himself and fellow
blues brother and SNL pal John Belushi
understanding that the original concept
would have made ghostbusters too
expensive to film Ramos helped reshape
the story but Belushi's untimely death
in 1982 threw a wrench into development
the movie was eventually rewritten into
the ensemble story we know and love with
Belushi there in spirit too according to
director Ivan Reitman the glowing green
ghost known as Slimer was conceived as a
tribute to Belushi it's not hard to tell
how Ramos and Aykroyd also wanted John
Candy to star as Louis Tully but candy
passed on the project the role
eventually went to Rick Moranis to top
things off before Ernie Hudson joined
the cast as winston zeddemore Aykroyd
originally wanted his Trading Places
co-star Eddie Murphy for the role Murphy
had to pass because he was shooting
Beverly Hills Cop but that's alright
because Ernie Hudson loves this town
just about everyone as Sam wheat despite
the wishes of ghost writer Bruce Joel
Rubin who wanted the role of Sam wheat
to go to Patrick Swayze director Jerry
Zucker went through a slew of noteworthy
actors - stars the film's death lothario
according to IMDB some of the names who
turned down the film's title role
include Johnny Depp Kevin Bacon Nicolas
Cage Kevin Costner Tom Cruise Harrison
Ford Mel Gibson Tom Hanks John Travolta
and Alec Baldwin even Bruce Willis who
was married to go star Demi Moore at the
time passed on the project eventually
Zucker came around to Ruben's way of
thinking which was definitely for the
past we really couldn't imagine any more
supernatural scenes with Nick Cave
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know which alternate
actors you would have liked you've seen
in these walls